[موسيقى]
مرحبا يسعدنا وبشرفنا اليوم
شارع الفارابي المتحدث الاول قام علميه
وثقافيه هامه جدا استطاع طوال مسيرته ان
يكون بمثابه بوصله للعديد من الاجيال هو
شخصيه ملهمه رصينه وحكيمه ترك رصيدا في
المكتبه العلميه والادبيه والفنيه بالكثير
من المساهمات الكريمه
استاذ ماده التشريح المرضي في كليه الطب
في جامعه دمشق ورئيس قسم التشريح المرضي
في مشفى الاسد والمواساه الجامعي رئيس
الرابطه السوريه لعلم الامراض ومؤسس قسم
علم الاورام في كليه الطب البشري في جامعه
دمشق كما كان العميد السابق لها وبالاضافه
لذلك كان وزير الصحه السابق اخيرا وليس
اخرا كان الرئيس اللجنه التنفيذيه في
منظمه الصحه العالميه رحبوا معي بمتحدث
برحله الى رحاب لاتنوبل من هون منصه شارع
الفارابي الاستاذ الدكتور اياد الشطي
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير
تسمحوا لي بدايه باسمكم اشكر هالمجموعه
الطيبه منك شابات وشبيبه يلي عم يقدموا
برنامج في الواقع هو برنامج عالمي ونحن عم
نستفيد منه اسمحوا لي رحب فيكم قامات
عديده
اداريه علميه ثقافيه لكن في قامتين لا
تكتسبان الا بالتدريج ولا تمنحان في عنا
اثنين مايسترو اسمحولي باسمكم رحي فيكم
بشكل خاص
نحن
موضوع نوبل موضوع كبير
ومن المتوقع والمنطق انه يكون اول مين حاج
على هذا الجائزه
نريدنا يلي
في الواقع صنع مجموعه من الامور الانسانيه
تحت اسم الصليب الاحمر او الهلال الاحمر
او الاسد الاحمر الى اخره فهاي فقط كانت
البدايه
ليش شبيبه اريد اعطيكم مثالين على مين اخذ
جائزه نوبل
يلي اخذوها باعماركم فيديو ما بدو
باعمارنا نحن بالرغم من انه نعتز بالخبره
بيكتسبناها خلال السنوات هذا الشاب
مارشل وهذا استاذ تشريح مرضي هذا طالب
سنه تانيه او ثالثه
باستراليا بده يعمل رساله الماجستير مثل
ما كثيرين منكم بدهم يعملوا فراح لعند
التسولوجيست قال له شو
عندك شيء قال له والله عم لاحظ انه
بالمعزه احيانا في جرثومه في الها
لوالب صغيره حاول انك تدرسها
هذا كان عام 1881
هل شاب هذا بدي الدراسه القرحه الهضميه
قرحه معروفه جدا ولغايه عام 2010 الحقيقه
العلاج تبعها كان بالحميه مضادات الحموضه
خذ حليب لا تاكل كذا لا اله اخره مرض
منتشر جدا
فهل شب هذا سنتي ال 81 بدي بالدراسه وفي
عنا نحن مقولات اذا بدك تثبت علاقه جرثوم
بمرض بدك تستخلصه
تزرعه
ترجعوا وتساوي مرض معه منسميها
بديهيه او فرضيه كوخ
كيف بده يساويها هذا الرجل
بديت حط بباله في شيء اسمه نوبل دجاني
توستاك
اخذ 25 حاله ما زبطت معه
ما عم تطلع نتائج متماثله
ضل عم بيدرس وعم بيحاول الجرع الجرعه
معروفه دائما 48 ساعه ما عم بيطلع شي 48
ساعه
لا الصدفه صار في عطله يومين بحيث انه
الجرعه استمرت اربعه ايام هل جرعه هاي
انتجت الجرثوم يلي هو الهليكوباكتور
ايلوري فاذا في اصرار وفي صدفه لكن
الاصرار هو الاساس لولا الاصرار ما كانت
صارت الصدفه
كيف بده يثبت انه بتعمل المرض راح
يجيش كامل
معبى جراثيم وصار معه بعد خمس ايام مجموع
امور
هالصوره هاي تذكروها ما تنسوها بجوز تنسوا
صورته هاي زوجته من البيت وحط العفش وراح
انه حدا مجنون بيعمل هيك
وهي الصوره من معدته لمارشل هي الجراثيم
وهي السبب التقرح واليوم علاج التقرح هو
كان بهالسبب
ضل مسابر امتى اخذ جائزه نوبل سنه 2005
قصه تانيه
ديفولتي دارسين سوا
بالمحاضرة القبول
لجائزه نوبل حط
وسكت حوالي 60 سنه بالسكوت وقت في محاضرات
بالسكوت تجذب انتباه اكثر من وقت بتحكي
فجذب انتباه بعدين قال في الواقع انا
الاكتشاف اللي عملته كان نتيجه على الاقل
خمسين الف ساعه عمل في كزم المستشفى في
كذا دوله لكن انا كنت محظوظ بحيث اني
الشيء الاخير انا يلي قمت فيه فاذا دائما
مثل ما عم نشوف في اصرار في عمل وفي انجاز
بده فتره ما نتهاون بسهوله ونقول ما وصلنا
لشيء بعد دراسه يومين او ثلاثه او عشره
ايام فهدول مثالين متباينين من حيث
الاعمار والى اخره لكن اعطونا فكره
بالعلوم قديش بدها جائزه نوبل يشتغل
الواحد
شابين
24 و33 سنه بجامعه
بيطلعوا هدول المخبر حقه عشره الاف
استرليني بهذاك الوقت سنه 1953
بيطلعوا بيروحوا لحقني جنب اغسل بالحان شو
بيشربوا الناس بشربوا مي
ضاجوا لسبب ما بتضوي
وقالوا نحن كسرنا الكود تبع الدي ان ايه
صرنا نعرف شو هو
تسع سنوات عم بيناضلو لسنه 62 بس في مؤسسه
كبيره مو شخص فرد وراهم لغدر يثبتوا انهن
كسروا الكود تبع الدي ان اي
تظهر نوع من القلق العلمي تشرفنا اشرت
الكود تبعديني يعني شو راح يصير معنا اوكي
بيطلع واحد اسمه مايكل بشر سنه 89 بيقول
انا عملت شويه تعديلات
بالثلاثه فاصله اثنين مليار متواليه في
الدي ان ايه الانساني شويه تعديلات قدرت
اعمل نوع من السرطان
عند نوع من الدجاج
وقال بهداك الوقت انت 89 اذا بدنا نطلع لي
مستوى ثاني من الطب بدنا نحكي عن الجينوم
عن الجينات المورثه
بدي مشروع كبير
هذا تعريف السرطان
خلايا شاذه وكذا والى اخره الكل بيعرفوا
هذا التعريف لكن هذا التعريف يلي بجهلنا
سنه 52 الحظ
نتيجه
اعمالها الشابين يلي كسروا الكون لاول مره
سنه 2006 عنا تعريف جديد للسرطان التعريف
مبني على الدي ان ايه وما يحدث من تبدلات
جينيه ما رح ندخل تفاصيل لمهم المبدا صار
عليه تعديل صغير سنه 2016
بناء على هدول صار عنا مستوى اخر من علاج
السرطانات والسرطان
ما بريد انا استعمل هذا الاسم لانه مربوط
بذهن مش بس المرضى كثير من الاطبها انه
مرض غير قابله للشفاء لا يا اخي
بجوز اصعب من غيره بشوي لكن مرض متبقيه
الامراض
وجائزه نوبل اخذوها
مو معناتها علاج بالكورتيزون او الى اخره
عم نعالج مناعيا الخلل اللي صار بالجينات
بدايه لانه بعض منا بسنتين صار في عنا شي
اسمه المقص الجيني ولكن
المقص جيني هل جزء من الجيني المخطئ خلينا
نقصه ونكبه مين اللي اكتشفوا كمان تنتين
صبايا من اعمار من اعماركم وحده فرنسيه
وحده امريكيه
احنا
بنحكي جينات وكذا معناتها في عالم وراثه
علم وراسي بتفتحوا الكتب بسوريا اليوم تبع
البكالوريا بيقولوا لكم انه يلي عملوهن
شخصين
مندل بشكل خاص في يستعملوه
يوم يلي بحكي عن التراث ما وغايتي
الاختباء بسنايا
وردائه فضفاض كتير بدنا اياه منصه
ننقذف فيه للمستقبل هي للشباب
خلينا نشوف شو عاملين ليش استعملت هالكلمه
ابن النفيس الدمشقي
1210 1288 شو قال بهذاك الوقت لا بيعرف
جينات ما في مجال ما بيعرف خليه ما بعرف
وهكذا في البهائم وحتى صغار الحشرات
تحمل في مكنونها اسرارها
تنقلها من جيل الى جيل
قد يطرا عليها تحسن او تراجع لكنها تبقى
محتفظه لنفسها بما يميزها عن غيرها من
الفصائل عم بحكي المورثات بكل ابعادها ولا
بيعرف شيء لكن في رؤيه ما بدنا نقول والله
نحن كنا هيك نحن كنا هيك قادرين نقفز انت
اللي قادرين نحنا نفتح لكم الطريق انتم
تمشوا
تتضاءل هديك الاكتشافات الحقيقه امام
الامور الانسانيه
خلينا نشوف طاغور سؤال قد لا تتبدى قدره
الاله بعواصفه العاتيه بقدر ما تتبدى
بنسماته الرقيقه او العليله خلينا نطلع
للشيء الانساني اخذ جائزه نوبل واعتقد
ماريسا بيحكوا عنا قديسه هاي شوفي شو قالت
بامريكا لا ريجن واجبي الا هل باستطاعتك
اشباع الفقراء الا مو هون المشكله هل
باستطاعتنا اشباع الاغنياء
وبتعرفوا شو مدلول هذا الكلام
عمره 17 سنه وقت اخدت
جائزه نوب الملاله من الباكستان
شوفي شو بتقول شي نحن بدنا اياها
بالاسلحه يمكن ان نقتل
اما بالعلم والثقافه
نقتل الارهاب
ما فينا وقت بنحكي عن امور انسانيه ما
نتطرق لمارتن لوثر كينج انا لدي حلم وقت
اجى كان بامريكا عم بعلمونا الديمقراطيه
بامريكا كان الباص بشي في له باب من قدام
باب من ورا اذا اللون مغاير بدك تطلع من
باب الوراني
ممنوعيد بتتعسفوا فيه ما بفتحوا الباب
الوراني بخلوه اذا مطر ثلج او كذا بخليهم
مسكر
فهو عمل شيء
له ثلاث كلمات
قاموس في الحياه
ثلاث كلمات محفوره في بجدا لفظ بمعنى
المحبه وليس الحب المحبه
المعرفه
وان نكون
موجودين حيث غيرنا بحاجه لنا
هدول الحقيقه يعني قامات فرديه يلي نالت
جائزه نوبل
حتى من بعيد كتير حتى ما سمعت
معظم يعني الامور في الها جائزه نوبل
ليش حطيت لاين
هذا عمل اكتشافات كيميائيه
اخذ عليه جائزه 54
شعر انه بلشت تستعمل لتطوير القنبله
الذريه الى قنبله هيدروجينيه
فحارب ما انتجوا من علم وضل عم يشتغل الى
انعام 62 اخذ جائزه نوبل السلام طبعا
بالسلام بعضها مسيس لكن بتشوفوا
مو كله يعني مسيسه بعض منها في الواقع
يستاهلوها البشر
باؤمن بها الشيء انا ما في شيء كبير
بالدنيا بصير اذا ما في وراه باشم عاطفي
شغف
هيك مو انا
نجيب محفوظ
نجيب محفوظ مين هو نجيب محفوظ
شخص نصري عمل ثلاثيه القاهره عام 52 او 53
بدي شهرتها منه مصرف صغير يظل ينتقل
بدوائر مختلفه بالقاهره
20 شهر
ويلي شهرته الحقيقه ثلاثيه القاهره
هالرجل هذا وصل لجائزه نوبل
وكيف دليها
دريها من خلال بائع صحف
رشح كذا الى اخره ما بيعرف يتابع
فيها ما بقدر مثل عبد الوهاب ما بيقدر
يركب طائره بيخاف منها الا في ظروف فبعد
شخص عوضه ليستلم جائزه
شو قال له
الخطاب تبعه خطاب راقي جدا
بيبدا يصغر حاله بعدين بعملك
من هو بقول لهم انا اقف امام نوبلتي
نوبلتي بمعنى انه طبقه النبلاء في
ستوكهولم وكذا اقف امام نوبلتي وعراقه
وكذا ضل ينفخ فيهم شي صفحه ونص اذا بينفخ
فيهم بعدين لكن بعدين انا تذكرت اني انا
ابن حضارتين حضاره عمرها 7000 سنه حضاره
الفراعنه
ولن اذكر لكم
انجازاتهم الملموسه وحكاها كلها بثلاث
صفحات الاهرامات وطولها وعرضها والى اخره
لكن اذكر لكم حادثه لتعلموا ما هي خلفيتي
من هون
احد ما بعرف شو كانوا يسوون الامبراطور
سلطان الى اخره
ياسره
صار في عنده مشكله بالبلاط
العاده كان انه هدول كلهم يعدموا
هالرجل هذا جاب 12 حكيم معروفين بحكمتهم
والهم خلفيه ما يمكن ان نسميه محاميه اللي
هي موضوع عراقي جدا وخلاهن يحكوا فقلن انا
بفتخر بالعدل يعني كان موجود
وليس الاهرامات مع انه عدل له اياها كلها
ثم قال بس انا ابن حضارتين هل حضاره هاي
تجاوشت مع حضاره عمرها 1400 سنه الحضاره
الاسلاميه
شو فتحوا قام وحطوا بس انا راح اسكن ليش
انا الحضاره الاسلاميه باحدى الغزوات
البيزنطيه
تغلبوا الاسلام واخذوا الاف الاسره
بادل الاسره على كتب علميه كتب ثقافيه
فحكى لهم عن الرغبه في الاطلاع والتطوير
حكى عنها الحضارتين
بدي انتقل معكم هلا لصديق عزيزه عليه
كلكم سمعانين فيه بس مثل مني ما بتعرفوا
وين ما بعرفه بغير قاره
بغير دين
بغير معتقدات
بس بحبو
قبل ما انتقل له نحن مع الاسف جائزه نوبل
بالموسيقى ما هي موجوده لكن هاي بيقولوا
اللي هي الفولار
بالسويد
هالشخص هذا اينشتاين هو اللي هون
اينشتاين
بالبدايات ما حدا بيعرف عنه شيء حاولت
البي بي سي سنه 1958 تتعرف عليه فطلع
عندها شغلك ما كانت معروفه عنه
شو طلع
ناضل من سنه 1905
1921 لاخذ جائزه نوبل معروف في جائزه نوبل
تتعلق بالقوه والزمن والاسهام
هالرجل هذا البي بي سي اكتشفت انه كان بحب
صبيه من البوسنه
ويبدو امه ما رضيت باي شكل انه
يتزوجها وحملت منه وراحت لبوشنيا والذي
تهنيك
يعتقد انه اسم البنت يلي ولدت هنيك اسمه
كم خطاب كل خطاب منهم جائزه نوبل لوحده
احد هذه الخطابات بالا
في قوه كتير كبيره بالدنيا اقوى من كل شيء
انا حكيته الى اخره
وتجمع كل القوى
بمعنى المحبه
يقول لا بخطاب اخر
الحب بيعطي معنى للحياه
طبعا ما عم بحكي عن شخص عم بحكي كيان قائم
وانا قديش متاسف انه قلبي طول الوقت كان
عم ينبض اليك بس ما قدرت وصل لك الرساله
ارجو ان لا يتهدج صوتي
اذا استبدلنا اينشتاين بالمواطن
بسوريا لقلنا
يا سوريا ستبقى قلوبنا
تنبض لك بالمحبه ما حيينا
ما بعمري اعطيت محاضره خارج سوريا الا في
عندي هالاخر
الرحمه لشهداء الوطن وحبه من ترابك بكنوز
الدنيا وشكرا لكم
[تصفيق]